after Hamas spent the weekend murdering
at least 900 Israeli civilians including
at least 140 children and babies the
terror group has received worldwide
condemnation from everyone with an even
mildly functioning moral conscience
which explains how it managed to receive
an endorsement from black lives matter
the official black lives matter Chicago
chapter took to social media yesterday
to express support for the Islamic
terror group with a picture of a
paraglider o the text I stand with
Palestine the paraglider of course
refers to the method by which the
terrorists circumvented Israeli
blockades and landed in the country
above the endorsement BLM wrote that is
all that is it meanwhile the BLM
Grassroots account took to social media
to Echo the endorsement writing quote
here it is black lives matter grassroot
stands in solidarity with our
Palestinian family who are currently
resisting 57 years of settler
colonialism and apartheid as black
people continue to fight to end
militarism and mass incarceration in our
own communities let us understand the
resistance in Palestine as an attempt to
tear down the gates of the world's
largest open air prison as a radical
black organization grounded in
abolitionist ideals we see clear
parallels between black and Palestinian
people
clear parallels between black and
Palestinian people the parallels being
that both are human and neither are
particularly
white that's about it though the
Palestinians actually look sort of white
they look more white than many Italians
actually and until recently they would
have been considered white in US
demographic statistics so no there
aren't very many parallels at all
between black people and Palestinian
Arabs there are however many peril
parallels between pramas activists and
BLM
activists that's the key for all of us
because the language used by pramas
activists is exactly the language used
by BLM activists and antifa and the
American left more
broadly what Hamas did to the Jews over
the weekend is precisely what BLM and
the rest of the left wants to do to all
of us and we deny that fact at our own
Peril I'm Michael nolles this is the
Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show you guys
remember that time that the former CIA
director suggested assassinating a
sitting US senator for opposing abortion
do you remember when that happened that
was yesterday that that happened we'll
get into that in one moment first though
I don't want to move off of BLM just yet
I think a lot of people are reading the
BLM endorsement of Hamas not even by the
way a BLM endorsement of the Palestinian
people or
Palestinian I don't know statehood or
something the endorsement was of one of
the paragliders who came in and
massacred the civilians
they didn't Massacre uniformed troops
they shot uniformed troops too they
massacred civilians and women and
children and babies who was an
endorsement explicitly of Hamas and a
lot of people are looking at that and
they're saying well yeah of course BLM
did that because BLM they're idiots or
because BLM they're evil or because BLM
they have a completely morally ined view
of the world maybe all of that is true
but the main reason the main reason that
BLM is endorsing Hamas
is because the arguments are exactly the
same BLM doesn't know anything about the
historical region of Palestine BLM
doesn't know or particularly care about
Arabs BLM is endorsing Hamas because
Hamas happens to be making the same
argument that BLM is making Hamas making
it in the context of Jews BLM making it
in the context of white people and Hamas
making it in the context of the nation
state of isra BLM making it in the
context of the United States got to give
a hat tip as usual to Libs of Tik Tok
here which found some random white
person making the decolonization link
between what Hamas is doing and what the
left wants to do in America colonization
is in its Reckoning
period um across so much of West Africa
and central Africa
we're seeing coups and we're seeing
uprisings and you know I'm not an expert
on the politics of Israel and Palestine
you don't say but it is also deeply
unsurprising to me saying what's
happening in
Palestine because right there you're
going to hear a lot about this this is
going to be a common refrain and most
people aren't going to notice it and the
refrain is look I don't really know
anything about the is Israel Palestine
conflict but here's my opinion here's
what I here's what I think is going I
don't know I don't know a damn thing
about it I've never cracked the cover of
a book one time but here's my very
important opinion that you should all
listen to keep going everyone is acting
like some people are acting confused and
the
Instinct
here given the
complexity is to see things in terms of
this is horrific what's happened to
Israel
but when you all
examined colonization and
decolonizing what did you actually think
that would look like what did you think
it would look like this woman who hasn't
and Australian or New Zealand or some
kind of you know Silly just slightly off
British accent I don't know where she is
she could be in the United States she
could be in Australia she could be in
timbuk too and she's making this
argument for all of the oppressed people
who have been colonized by the evil
white man in Europe and in particular
the British man they're going to throw
off the shackles and they're going to
rise up and Liberation and
decolonization well you know what it
looks like it looks like murdering women
and children and that's what they're
calling for and they're calling for that
here which is why now is a very good
time to pray and when you want to pray
one tool that might help you pray is
hallow right now go to hall.com with
everything going on in the world there
is no better time to build a daily habit
of prayer and meditation building a
habit of prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude focusing on
what you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being also it's a duty that you
owee to God so you should pray hallo is
the number one Christian Prayer app in
the US it has helped a lot of people
maintain a daily prayer routine it can
help you too download the app for free
at hall.com nesk wle you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start check
out father Mike Schmid's Bible in a year
available on the Hallow app for brief
daily readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim cisel even
some worldclass athletes like me no I'm
not on there yet but I and I'm also not
I'm not a world okay with hallow you can
customize a personal prayer plan that
works for you listen wherever you are
with downloadable offline sessions use
hello to connect to others who share
your beliefs and Foster a sense of
community right now go to hall.com
SNES get an exclusive 3 months free that
is hall.com get three months absolutely
free the decolonization argument is key
here people care about what happens in
the holy land they care in part because
we hate to see innocent people killed or
treated cruy or with injustice people
care about what happens in the Holy Land
more than say what happens in Ukraine or
something because it's the Holy Land
because we all have an interest in the
Holy Land we all have a natural
inclination toward a longing for the
holy land a connection that we might not
even be able to quite articulate but we
feel that connection to the Holy Land
that's that's in part why people care
more about what's going on there but
even if you don't care at all you don't
care about the nation state of Israel
you don't care about the Palestinian
Arabs you don't care about Lebanon you
don't care about Egypt you don't care
about Iran or any of that
stuff the arguments for what Hamas did
and is doing
apply to the us as well and why is that
why is BLM why do BLM and Hamas sound
exactly the same when they're talking
about what seem to be totally different
issues the reason for that is the
historical circumstances in which the
modern nation state of Israel came to be
are extremely similar to the historical
circumstances in which the United States
came to be I'm not talking about the
historical and Theological claims that
justify the existence of the nation
state of Israel I'm not talking about
the claims that go back to Antiquity I'm
talking about the historical
circumstances in which those claims came
to have a practical
effect I'm talking about the 19 century
the the origins of the modern nation
state of Israel date back to the 19th
century to the rise of Zionism and then
sanism really starts to take off in the
latter part of the 19th century it then
gets a a land Grant a promise from the
British in 1917 and then the nation
state of Israel was founded in
1948 those circumstances going back to
the early 19th century are the
circumstances of nationalism don't
forget 1848 is the year that all of
Europe was set on fire 1848 is the year
and it's probably not even really taught
in schools anymore 1848 is the year of
revolutions you had Revolutions in Italy
France Germany Belgium Sweden
Switzerland
everywhere everywhere you have
revolutions that begin around
1948 and why is that because of a surge
in nationalism you saw a decline of
Empire you saw a decline of monarchy and
that really all collapses that
culminates in the first World War uh no
coincidence in the first world war when
the British issued the the Bal for
declaration that says we're going to
reserve some land in the holy land for
the Jews to have a nation
state the very fact
that it was the British who gave the
United States our country we kind of
fought him a little bit for it but the
British were pretty involved in setting
the whole thing up and the British were
also pretty involved the British Empire
was pretty involved in setting up the
nation state of Israel is I think a lot
of the reason why you're seeing
similarities between the BLM argument
and the Hamas argument uh even going
back to the the American
Revolution which was an attack on the
Age of Empire it was an attack on the
British Empire it was a turning away
from monarchy toward this new modern
nation state way of doing things and so
as history has rolled along and you've
seen a reconsideration a Vil an outright
vilification of Empire of tradition of
basically anything that came before the
latest surges in political fads you are
seeing the the
rhetoric uh be mirrored in in all of
those places and so it's some it's
sometimes said that uh you know Israel's
enemies are America's enemies which is a
practical matter is largely true it's
not totally true but it's largely true
uh but it it doesn't mean that Hamas is
going to come over here and set off a
bomb it could we've had Islamic Terror
attacks in the United States that
certainly could
happen but I think the deeper meaning of
that is the the argument against the
nation state of Israel can pretty just
as easily be applied to the United
States and is being applied to the
United States and if that argument is
allowed to succeed and gain currency
it's going to redound to our detriment
here in the good old us OFA speaking of
nationalism uh I know Ukraine is kind of
yesterday's news no one really talks
about Ukraine anymore that people have
lowered the flags now that's not that's
that's not in the news but you remember
there was that
American
[Music]
bringing all of this together how do you
bring together BLM and the war now in
the Middle East and the weird LGBT stuff
you do it in the context of Rashida
Talib a democrat congress lady
who has has a a lot of flags outside of
her office she's got on the door of her
office it's the United Auto Workers
stand up to save the American
dream probably the main reason the UAW
is even striking is because of the
regulations passed by Joe Biden to
destroy their industry but that's a
topic for another time then in the flag
in the most prominent position outside
of Rashid tb's office is the Palestine
flag the red green white and black then
next to that flag is the flag of the
state of Michigan okay then the flag of
the city of Detroit and then the gay
flag not even the new gay flag it's the
old gay flag she doesn't even have the
triangle with you know the
militant quarter of the flag that's not
there yet she she needs to update that
that's a very outdated and offensive old
timey gay flag uh you notice a flag
that's
missing just one flag she got a lot of
flags there she does not want for for
flag poles around her office and yet
there's one flag that's missing
that would be the American flag not
there not there if this picture doesn't
sum up the American left I don't know
what does you've got the Palestine flag
on one side and the gay flag on the
other and if one of the guys that the
gay flag represents ever made his way
into the West Bank or Gaza he would be
thrown from a rooftop but Rashida
talib's no contradiction here I don't
know how many pal inian refugees are
Marching In West Hollywood Pride parades
probably not very many those two
flags don't have a lot to do with one
another but they do at an at a deep
level which is they Flags to upend the
current order they are flags that oppose
the
oppressors they and they agree on who
the oppressors are they agree on who the
people the bad people are who need to be
Tak care of and the bad people are us
the bad people are just normal ordinary
largely American Western traditional
kind of
people and the solution that Rashida
Talib has for
that the solution that the BLM people
have for that the solution that the
American left broadly whether they're
willing to admit it or not and a hell of
a lot of them are willing to admit it is
the solution that you saw Hamas use over
the weekend the paragliders that be M
endorses the attacks on civilians
because the the left makes no
distinction between political and
private they don't really make a
distinction between civilian and
uniformed Soldier that's it that's what
it's about the bad guys are the ordinary
traditional Americans that's why there's
no American flag outside of Rashida
talib's office lot of Chaos in the world
that's why when you want to protect your
assets you might want to check out Birch
gold text nolles to 98 9898 the G20 the
group of 20 is an international forum
for governments and Central Bank
Governors who was established in
response to the financial crisis of the
late 90s with the aim of promoting
International Financial stability how's
that been going last month the G20
announced a plan to impose digital
currencies and digital IDs on their
respective populations Central Bank
digital currencies essentially allow the
government to track every purchase you
make even if you don't follow
International economic policies all that
closely you got to be concerned you
should consider diversifying at least
some of your assets into physical gold
with the help of Birch gold call Birch
gold today to preserve your savings in a
tax sheltered retirement account if you
have an IRA or 401K from a previous
employer that is just Gathering dust
call Birch gold they will help you
convert it into an IRA in Gold you will
not pay a penny out of pocket they will
simply convert that 401k that's just
sitting in a bank somewhere into
physical gold which cannot be tampered
with text Nes canw to 98 9898 Birch gold
will send you a free info kit on gold if
digital currency becomes a reality you
will be glad to have something physical
to fall back on text nolles kwes to 98
9898 claim your free info kit on gold
today Jeremy's chocolate is offering a
special 25% discount just in time for
Halloween we all know that woke candy
companies out there think that
Frankenstein can become his own bride
who writes this copy who who are we
paying a salary to to to that's why
Jeremy's chocolate launched our she her
and he himars only one of which has nuts
and what could be more fun than to share
in Jeremy's chocolates in the
microaggression size that's right don't
miss out on our newest edition to
Jeremy's anti-woke chocolate lineup the
dlns today make sure that you get your
order in to get 25% off go to Jeremy
chocolate.com and order now to get it in
time for
Halloween speaking of claims of
Oppression big story
in the LA Times black people are fleeing
the United States because of the
oppression and the colonialism and the
imperialism and the ism and the racism
and the
ismism America does not deserve me why
black people are leaving the United
States says the LA Times now because
this is the LA times I have a good hunch
going into this article that whatever it
says is not true but here's what the
article
says filmmaker jamaa nedine was locked
down in La during the pandemic watching
as the nation convulsed in protest over
the murder of George Floyd when she had
an epiphany America does not deserve me
as a black woman Nori Dean always tried
to work twice as hard as those around
her thinking if I'm smart enough pretty
enough successful enough then finally
people will treat me as a human being
but she grieved yet another unarmed
black man killed by police she decided
she was done trying to prove herself to
a society that she felt would never
really love her back so Dean 39 packed
her bags and left she now spends her
days working for us clients in Chic
cafes in the Caribbean leading healing
ceremonies at a local waterfall and
trying to figure out who she is exactly
outside of an American context it's like
leaving an abusive relationship she said
of exiting the United States okay lot in
there but the major claim is black
people are fleeing the United States
because of of racism and Injustice and
that is just not true and here's how I
know for a fact that that's not
true how many what was the net movement
of black people into and out of the
United States over the last say 20
years
roughly 3 million into the United States
not out it wasn't a mass Exodus it was
people moving in 2 million from Africa 1
million from the Caribbean they moved
into they immigrated into the United why
would they immigrate into the United
States if America is terribly racist and
evil and unjust and racist cops go
around slaughtering black black men
innocent people all the time why would
they do that because they know that
that's not true because they know that
it's actually pretty good in the United
States for black people and for most
other people because they know that not
only will they not have trouble getting
a
job because of the color of their skin
they know that they'll have extra help
getting a job because of the color of
their skin not only will they not have a
harder time getting into college because
of the color of their skin they'll have
an easier time getting into college
because of the color of their skin
because we have not only de facto but
deure racial discrimination in the
United States on behalf of black people
and Hispanic people to a lesser degree
and against white people and Asian
people to a lesser degree that has
technically been struck down in months
because the Supreme Court uh struck down
affirmative action in college admissions
but the college is all just admitted
they're just going to figure out a way
to hide it now and they they'll hide it
in the personal statement just just
completely made up but this narrative
the reason I bring it up this narrative
which we we know you know I'm skeptical
of Statistics but certain statistics
like how many people come in how many
people go out are pretty
solid uh at least when it comes to Legal
immigrant illegal immigration the Biden
Administration is a little weaker on but
un legal immigration it's pretty clear
black people are coming into the United
States we we can know for a fact that
that is the behavior and yet this
narrative prevails and the narrative is
very very powerful that narrative burned
down half the country for about eight
months during the George Floyd
riots that narrative
shapes many many people not just black
people it shapes the views of white
liberals it shapes the views of all
sorts of people all sorts of liberal
people who
are mistaken but those mistaken
ideologies can have horrific effects and
impel people to do very very terrible
things that's what you're seeing in this
campaign for
decolonization which is which is aiming
toward we saw it over the weekend prove
positive we saw it in the endorsements
of BLM it is aiming toward violence
against civilians against men women
children and little babies they want to
come kill us because they've convince
themselves of a bogus narrative even if
that historical narrative were true and
it's not it still would not justify
their actions there is no moral or
ethical justification for the targeting
of
civilians they don't know that these are
very very confused people and what's
very dangerous is not just that they're
confused it's a fallen world and people
have defects of intellect and will
what's dangerous is that narrative has
been pushed by the most elite segments
of our country in the media in Academia
in government
in entertainment everywhere everywhere
and so it's taken hold doesn't
necessarily matter that it's not true it
can have real effects in the world
speaking of immigration a little bit of
good
news as America lets in millions and
millions of illegals across the border
every single year they decided they were
finally going to exercise immigration
law and enforce it by kicking out a nice
Conservative Christian German
homeschooling family forget about MS-13
that's
raping and pillaging and murdering and
pedaling drugs across the border those
guys get to operate with impunity they
are the poor oppressed dreamers ignore
their face tattoos and their Satan
worshiping rituals no no no they're
they're future undocumented happy
dreaming Americans we need to just
release them into the interior but the
nice German family that Minds its own
business and takes care of itself and
and is actually fleeing political
persecution in Germany where they're not
allowed to homeschool and raise their
kids according to their faith and the
ones who you know pay their taxes and do
their jobs and have kids and are just
normal and reasonable and decent they
have to be deported so that that story
came out a few weeks ago even though
they've been in the United States since
2008 well a source has just reported
yesterday that the family has received a
one-year reprieve from
deportation why did did immigration
enforcement did the Biden Administration
realize the error of their ways and the
Injustice here no of course not they
just got caught and they were getting
pressure from Congress they were getting
pressure from some conservative leaders
who still have a modicum of political
power in the US and they knew this was
this was a bad look and they knew it was
just so transparent that the Biden
Administration is going to invite into
the country its allies namely terrorists
and gangsters and drug dealers and
rapists and murderers they were going to
invite them in and release them into the
country with impunity but they were
going to deport the Biden
administration's enemies namely nice
Christian homeschoolers from Germany who
have a nice
family they had to go and it look it was
so transparent that the the way that
this Administration operates the way the
liberal establishment broadly operates
is not according to the rule of law of
course they the border is wide open they
operate according to rewarding friends
and punishing enemies two tiers of
Justice BLM doesn't doesn't barely get a
slap on the wrist and uh the the
midwestern Granny's on January 6 the
worst day in history they they get
thrown in solitary confinement for 40
months it just looked so bad that okay
this one gets away this one they get one
more year and then hopefully it dies
down in the news and they can Deport
them
then it's good news I'll take the win
well we've got it but the the problem is
far from over you want to talk about our
corrupt deep
State the former CIA director Michael
Hayden responded to a post on Twitter
now known as X which is should
Republican senator Tommy tuberville be
removed from his
committee and general former CIA
director Michael Hayden
says how about the human
race if I were Tommy tuberville I'd be
sleeping with one eye open because
that's not an empty
threat
it's something that the CIA has been
known to do once or twice to engage in
political
assassination it's something we've seen
increasing political violence in recent
years we've seen calls forget about the
CIA we've seen calls from liberals more
broadly to attack conservatives not not
armed soldiers but conservative leaders
some public officials push back on them
go to their homes where their children
sleep we were that from Maxine Waters
don't you can't be civil with people who
disagree with you that was Hillary
Clinton Eric Holder former Obama
attorney general all these
guys not exactly an empty threat it does
give a decent picture of our government
and here's the decent picture there's a
little silver lining to the former CIA
director calling for the assassination
of a sitting Senator the Silver Lining
is if the CIA actually wanted to take
this guy out they probably would do it
if the CIA were what people imagine the
CIA to be if if the Deep state were were
omnipotent as people believe it to be
then they would just do this stuff right
they wouldn't post about it on Twitter
they would just start killing senators
and they don't do that because the Deep
State even the CIA the vaunted
CIA they're not Ubi they're not
omnipotent and they're not ubiquitous
for that matter and they're
not they've got a lot of power but they
they don't have total
power and they control enough to become
irate when our duly elected lead
exercise power that's the most telling
part about this to me is the the
indignance that you see from Michael
Hayden what why does he want to
assassinate Tommy tuberville because
Tommy tuberville is asking the Pentagon
to resend its new policy to pay service
members to go all around the country to
kill their babies he says that's a bad
use of Pentagon funds that's a bad
policy it's a new policy we don't like
it so stop stop that we want the US
military to kill our enemies not to kill
American
babies we think about the horror when we
read in the news of babies being
murdered been in the news quite a lot
I'm sorry to say recently Tommy
tuberville shares that horror says well
the unit the United States government is
now making that its policy the Pentagon
is now making it a top priority to kill
the children of American Service members
or else what Tommy tuille says if you
don't resend the policy I'm going to
hold up your promotions so you're not
going to have as many generals as you
want you're not going to have as much of
the top brass of the Pentagon which is
the real problem here the real problem
isn't the enlisted guy in the middle of
the country the real problem isn't the
normal guy who kept his head down at
West Point or the Naval Academy and
became an officer or went through OCS
and he's he's perfectly ordinary and he
doesn't want to put up with all this
woke nonsense the real problem is that
top brass it's the top brass that's
whining and huffing and puffing about
white rage and the need to to read
critical race Theory to be a fighting
force the top brass is the one pushing
the and Military policies they're the
problem and the top brass they're the
ones that are promoting infanticide for
American Service members and Tommy
tuberville says no if you're really so
and and then the Pentagon says well
you're endangering National Security Oh
no you're endangering National Security
if you think that America faces an
existential threat right now and you
need the promotions then resend your new
and insane infanticide policy and then
you get your generals well no we're not
willing to do that oh so I okay you
would rather an attack on the American
Homeland you would rather the American
Military not be able to fight and defend
our national interest than give up your
infanticide policy okay tells me
everything I need to know about the top
brass good none of you are getting your
promotions good and what this tells you
then about the Deep State and the CIA
types like Michael Hayden is not that
they actually pull every single one of
the strings no Tommy tuberville pulls
some strings strings here the US Senate
still pulls some
strings but it shows you that these
unaccountable people have enough
influence that they would become irate
when the Senate especially Republicans
in the Senate actually exercise their
power that's such a rarity Republicans
aren't supposed to do that Republicans
are just supposed to send out
fundraising emails supposed to send out
some tweets maybe write some strongly
worded letters but they're never
supposed to wield power for conservative
ends that's crazy uh-uh they don't
they're not supposed to set policy were
supposed to set policy in the Deep
State my favorite comment yesterday is
from Graham Tres 1114 who says finally
someone corrects I could care less thank
you
Michael it's my pleasure I try not to I
remember I read I think it was in Strunk
and white that unless you are an English
teacher you should not correct
somebody's English but when I see some
lib on Tik Tok or something
some leftwing prominent person and they
use a phrase like that it just it greats
and I take the Liberty to correct them
if you could care less about something
it means you care about it somewhat the
phrase is you could not care less is
then you don't care about it at
all the more you know I want one of
those NBC Little Star logos to come
across speaking of duly elected leaders
we have a race for the house speaker on
right now this information is going to
become outdated the moment I say it in
fact even in real time as I'm speaking
it's probably all changed but the way
the race is set up uh you've got Jim
Jordan a favorite of conservatives and
Steve scales who conservatives also like
but he's a little bit less conservative
and he's been in House of leadership a
little bit a little bit longer he's been
on the leadership track unlike Jim
Jordan who is Chairman of the Judiciary
Committee uh there is a behind closed
doors kind of debate conversation with
the two candidates so they're going to
hash out their differences this is not
meant for the public because the public
doesn't vote on the house Speaker the
house speaker is elected by the members
of Congress so they they had that last
night uh according to DW nominate which
is not run by us sadly but it's it's a
metric that political scientists
sometimes use to gauge people's
political views according to that uh Jim
Jordan is the more conservative
candidate the first dimension of DW
nominate describes how
liberal or conservative the members are
and then the second dimension reveals uh
how closely aligned the members are with
the establishment so those are those are
not synonymous issues uh and they're
both kind of relevant so according to DW
nominate the average Jordan backer is
more conservative than 69% of House
Republicans so all in all pretty pretty
solid you know not more conservative
than
99% not total Rock rib Tilla the hun
style but more conservative than most
House Republicans that's a pretty good
sign and more anti-establishment than
73% of them that's a good sign scales's
average supporter is more conservative
only than 37% of the GOP membership
that's not a good sign that's and
scales's average supporter is more
anti-establishment than just 30% of the
GOP caucus so that's not good uh scales
is fine he would probably be better than
some previous speakers that we've had I
really like Jim Jordan I think he he
could be a good speaker the only reason
I hesitate to endorse him is one speaker
always going to disappoint you because
they've got a rank they've got a herd
cats with that Republican conference but
two it's a it's the worst job in
Washington and I wouldn't wish it on a
good guy like Jim Jordan the other thing
is it could also be McCarthy so if
scalise and Jordan are not able to get a
clear win here and with a razor thin
majority for Republicans you know the
Democrats might end up picking the speak
speaker which is one of the reasons that
it was a little bit risky to to oust
Kevin McCarthy it could be McCarthy too
McCarthy said he's not going to run for
it again but he might just get elected
he might you know campaign behind the
scenes or say that he'd be willing to do
it and then he could just wind up the
speaker again there's there's one other
option which is the one that I know
we're all Holding Out for not because it
would necessarily be the most effective
thing or uh conducive to conservative
policy but it would certainly be the
funniest and that is speaker Trump uh
Donald Trump has
suggested that he might consider being a
temporary speaker the man does not want
to be the actual speaker of the house
and he doesn't want to be the speaker of
the house because he's running for
president and he's up 50 points on his
opponents and I'm not sure he can win
the general but he he's almost certainly
going to lock up the GOP nomination and
so he says I want to be speaker when I
could get the real job but he has
suggested he might be willing to step in
temporarily I think this would be great
I strongly encourage this even if it's
only for five seconds
because do Donald Trump is a world
historic figure whether you love him or
hate him he's just different from the
other presidents that we've had before
and so it would be very Charming if he
could be the president and the speaker
of the house and then what he has to do
and I don't know if the timing will work
but if he does somehow manage to make it
back to the White House he's got to
nominate himself for the Supreme Court
so that he can have served in all three
branches government ideally for uh chief
justice I not again not because he's
qualified to be in the Supreme Court not
because he's necessarily the best choice
for speaker I do think he was an
excellent president but really just
because it would be super duper funny
and I would really enjoy
that now speaking of a return to decent
government this is really good news and
especially coming after Columbus Day you
know Columbus Day is one of my favorite
holidays Christopher Columbus much
maligned uh the American left was too
busy sing for Hamas this year to engage
in their usual attacks on Christopher
Columbus one of the great men of history
who helped to found our entire
civilization in the new world uh but and
and a wonderful product of the old world
too and a a great devout Catholic and
just a a very impressive man who made it
across the ocean blue with dead
reckoning in his own grit and prayers
and Faith uh but
I I was off on Columbus Day I like the
idea of taking Columbus Day off okay I
like the idea of acknowledging this good
man and this good
holiday there's some good news as the
statues have been falling for years and
years and they malign Columbus with the
same arguments that you hear from the
pramas side and the BLM side and antifa
in the left they say he was a
colonizer he was an imperialist he was a
white man he was bad he was just he was
Catholic Oh the worst thing he's cathol
oh no uh well we hear all of that in
recent years one little town in
Providence decided to put a statue back
up or one little town in Rhode Island
not Providence put a statue back up that
would be uh Johnston Memorial Park in
Johnston Memorial Park in Johnston Rhode
Island they took a statue that had been
taken down in Providence and they moved
it over to this town and they put it
back up this was thanks to to Providence
former Providence mayor Joe poino good
son of Italy who purchased the old
statue and brought it over to this nice
town why is this such a great story it's
such a great story not because we're all
going to take trips to Johnston Rhode
Island though maybe we should not
because it's not a bad thing that the
bigger towns and the bigger cities
Providence and all over the even New
York wants to take these statues down
it's not that not that we've made it out
of the woods that they're going to keep
their statues up but it means means
that we can restore things we don't need
to just shrug our shoulders and AED to
the the left's absolute destruction of
our
civilization the the lib cities want to
take down the Columbus statues the
conservative towns can put them back up
the lib cities want to take away
parents' rights the conservative towns
can say come on over here if you want to
raise your kids the cons the liberal
cities want to enshrine the rainbow flag
and
the conservative towns can say we're not
going to tolerate that here we
got and if you're an adult and you talk
to kids about weird sex stuff you're
going to get arrested and if you are an
adult and you try to put some weird
obscene material into schools and
libraries you're going to get
arrested we can do that no antifa is not
there tearing that statue down in
Johnston Rhode Island not just yet you
could do it in your town too hope is not
lost we can return we're not going to go
back in time we're going to keep going
forward in time but we can turn toward
the right direction the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
become a member use code NS KW has a
check out for two months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans